welcome to this video playing even death
I been deaths I don't know even Wow
Yvonne desert Nick off okay with the
Japan flag interesting doesn't sound
very Japanese to me anyway even got a
king's indian playing this line which i
have played a bit in the past but never
really studied that much something that
will change very shortly going to look
at this age three line in lots of detail
because i really want some so good
weapon against the Kings Indian finally
and this seems to be quite good okay I'm
96-95 what is this come on guys you
can't be serious you're just giving you
a pawn for nothing here it's amazing
sometimes I mean okay i know it's blitz
chess but why play something where
you're just a pawn down and have a dead
bishop on g7 and you're just lost yeah i
mean the only chance now for black is
white blunders stuff or place completely
brain dead which i might do I mean and
tend to do this but why go for this in
the first place it's it's totally
obvious that it's unplayable of a black
ok anyway so what do I do now night if
495 maybe or just before a fall okay I
guess 94 come on so what is the best
here look see one maybe just looking at
c7 okay so if i go before he might go to
a eight
night c5 would be a very technical kind
of continuation not really a bad one but
a bit probably a bit too technical hmm
you can also just really go B form okay
I can take this 726 so there come on
let's do that it's as I said it's a very
technical way of playing but why not
just a 4 a 5 and so on check so there
three is not very desirable but I can't
do this it's not really I mean it
doesn't really have any counter attack
also on my king where are the pieces for
that
so Roxy one is actually not look see
what is actually not that easy to win
the threatening would be five
hmm
yeah okay check check hmm when i get to
be seven here with the look covering
from the side so i think each for should
be right each for cannot move the king
chief i take for another pawn yeah and
then I got over with the king okay jack
so what let's activate the King now king
and queen no g4 h5 check now that should
have been much much easier I really
played this badly
so now like age 6 what do I bring the
king of hmm it's not so clear actually
time warning
I can do that actually King g5 rookie 7
well then then it's right King age six
rupees six check now you have to win win
this position King edge six roommates at
ruby six which is still slightly tricky
with the time yes why didn't you check
this would have been still something to
do glad movers eyes green again struck
with 40 seconds something yeah yeah I'm
sorry when sometimes a bit I don't I
just don't get it I mean he's an
international marseille and so no pizza
and big be five it's lost after that
position is just completely completely
lost and it's not necessary at all I
mean you can play any normal move why do
I start with the lost position on move
10 I don't don't forget it it's just a
matter of jamming your spoiled for
choice with white and what I did is not
even the best I guess I mean I'm okay up
to here maybe it's maybe this is really
a bit too technical but yeah it's still
a winning position without any any doubt
but I playing this badly now I should be
should play this song should play this
better so look here ok probably
designing them again but I'm screwing up
later somehow be 75 probably ok the
computer of course finds f4 and black
and resign that's very easy actually
once you see it it feels like child's
play yeah and the the two passes win-win
quite easily
okay I didn't see that one and now it
gets slow gets kind of tricky it gets
kind of tricky okay King f2 is better
why didn't I do that so this check check
and now g4 yeah this is a better version
of the game I guess chanda well the
engine just gives a complete wind
provide all of the time no no not
anymore g5 supposed to but I have cut
off cut by doubts IAM really felt like
and I screw this up a little bit yeah
look after this I'm I'm winning again
but you look before is given by the
computer probably just to avoid this
trick on the sixth-ranked now it's very
difficult for me to keep that pawn yeah
no no it'sit's winning again because of
this IDM check just worried what didn't
you try that I mean okay of course it's
a win but well you still have to win
with Queen against against truck and
that that he has the porn it's not that
relevant I will probably win that win
that part somehow but yeah you still
have to do it in 40 seconds it was nice
that he just gave away the rook and
allow the simple win okay well thanks
for watching